entire life you had
many people talk to you about your
weight
and it was always i'm not listening to
you i'm not doing this
and someone comes along
and you're listening and that's i mean
you you knew something
it's this was the love of your life this
was somebody that you you for the first
time you saw a future and you listened
to her was
was she really the first person that you
were like all right someone's helping
someone's actually going on this journey
with me i'm not alone it was the first
time
that i was invested that it that i was
the one going like i want to change
it was not it was it was the very first
time it wasn't somebody going like
here's what you're gonna do
despite what you want um
and you know like is there a way that i
could have been invested as a kid if my
parents had used different language with
maybe i don't know but all i know is as
a kid
it was now you're gonna eat this way
and and here's why because you're fat or
because you're overweight and it's not
healthy and all of this stuff
which just compounded how i felt badly
about myself
um and made me rebel and and
and ultimately you know i got really bad
when i became
autonomous and was making money and was
really just living
for the moment and doing whatever i
wanted
with no restraint um but yeah it was the
first time i went hey i need help with
this i want to change
i will do whatever you tell me which i
think i i've also had success being
sober in that way
um and and in talking to people about
sobriety like i have no interest
in my wife is not sober and i have no
interest in anyone
um in trying to make somebody sober like
this is not my mission
at all in fact to the point where i've
had people say will you talk to my kid
or will you talk to my friend
and it's like no because
any it didn't work for me and i don't
have the understanding of making it work
for somebody else by
pleading with them or describing some
utopian future by changing your behavior
i know it works when the individual goes
i want to make a change
that's that's how i've seen it work
that's how i've experienced it work
and so the kind of the same thing with
food i think if you asked yourself
for many years of your life if you know
that that stupid question that people
are like that's such a stupid question
when you say uh
do you love yourself but it would have
been easy for you to say no i don't
it sounds like right for most of your
life i i could say that a lot of my life
i would probably say
what no no i don't i
sometimes i think i'm all right i
sometimes like myself i love myself i
how do you love yours that's a lot
to say i don't love anyone
it's just such a mind boggle that people
are like you should be able to say you
love yourself pretty easily
and that always with me because
it never was easy
to go yeah yes i love myself that's not
something that occurs to me at all so
when did you start do you i mean do you
now feel like you're loving yourself
more
i mean obviously i feel like it's been
very helpful to be responsible for other
people
and by doing that i have to be
responsible for myself
and and and and i do think i've learned
to have
um certainly a higher level of
admiration for myself
especially when it's like um
setting and achieving goals and sticking
to things that i've made decisions about
because i was not good at that forever
so
this idea of love i don't know yeah it's
a very abstract thing for me
too you know but you love other people
when you love your kids you love your
wife
obviously yeah you know you're on an
airplane and they tell you like if we
have to do
oxygen masks you got to put your oxygen
mask on
first because if you pass out trying to
put your kids oxygen mask on
then they don't get theirs either so in
that way
i think that's a road to loving yourself
right if you can yeah kind of play this
mental hopscotch a little bit where
you're right i have to treat myself
well because i have people dependent on
me and
and i actually love my wife
and the fact that she loves me and i and
i
i don't have a really a critical thought
about her
leads me to believe there's something
lovable about me you know it's
absolutely gymnastics that we have to
play